hey everybody is Charlie you guys asked
me to do a flash Batman button video but
this recent issue of Batman is a
continuation of that so I will address
what happened during that story arc
which is careful for spoilers from the
recent issues of flash and Batman so
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video but this week's Batman is probably
one of the best deep dives into what's
going on up in his head the bat psyche
it's all about him addressing his fears
and what his father said to him during
the flash crossover so just to go back
into the flash button storyline they got
sucked into an alternate flashpoint
timeline that flash believed had been
cancelled out when he went back and
allowed his mother to die in the grander
sense of things in the DC rebirth
universe right now all of the comics are
being influenced by dr. Manhattan in The
Watchmen so as part of that Bruce winds
up talking to Thomas Wayne his father
the Thomas Wayne who was Batman during
flashpoint and his father tells him
don't be Batman anymore
your mother and I didn't want this for
you take the cowl off start a family be
happy
in Batman flips out because his parents
death is what catalyzed him to become
the bat in the first place his whole
life is based on that moment in Crime
Alley so in the way that Batman isn't a
very emotional character he gets
extremely emotional it's just that he
keeps it all underneath you sense it all
going on behind his eyes but there are a
couple times that he starts openly
weeping and one of them was when he read
the flashpoint letter
[Music]
you're one hell of a messenger so he
meets his father his father says don't
be Batman anymore
and he spends the next couple of issues
of his comic book just wrestling with
that decision what do I do now
even when Alfred it sees the bat-signal
go on and Bruce does nothing he asked
him aren't you going to answer that and
it's implied that he's going to listen
to his father and he will lay the mantle
of the bat down but then in this issue
they directly addressed that because
Gotham girl if you're not familiar with
her she's just another character they
introduced during rebirth that has crazy
powers in his trying to be a hero
Batman's trying to help guide her but
she doesn't know what she wants to do
with her life do I be a hero what am I
supposed to do now in much to his
chagrin Batman doesn't have any answers
for her why you asking me Alfred didn't
give me any answers when my parents died
so as he's trying to help her out he
starts talking about his own experience
in trying to find out what he should be
doing with his life what he decided to
do after Crime Alley the whole reason
for him wearing the cow he says what's
normal I'm not Batman because I like
being Batman I'm Batman
because I'm Batman he's been doing this
for so long that is just who he is it's
not a persona that he wears it's not
like other costumed heroes like he sort
of makes light of people that dress up
in costumes just to be heroes like I'm
going to be a hero so I'm going to put a
costume on and go help people he treats
it like an extension of himself it's
part of me it's Who I am I don't think I
can stop and I'm not happy but I try to
be I try and I fail so those are some of
the most important lines there's the big
Catwoman twist and I'll get to that in a
second obviously that's the thing that
most people are talking about this whole
idea that he's seen the truth of things
and he's afraid like he says what I've
seen
Gotham him if you're not scared if all
that doesn't scare me that I'm insane
and I don't want to be insane so I'm
scared so he just haunted by reality and
he doesn't know exactly how to deal with
it so he's terrified and it's destroyed
most of his relationships because even
though he has Damian he has all the
Robins he does have people that are
close to him he's never been comfortable
not being Batman he's Batman 24/7 the
bruce wayne's that you see when he's
small ting around with women is just a
mask that he wears the other really
important line in here this would
normally be an Alfred line of dialogue
but she says I mean getting scared
everybody is scared but that just means
that everybody gets an opportunity to
fight that fear we have a chance to be
brave in embracing that opportunity to
be brave is what makes you a hero what
do we folks so don't we look to myself
so Batman being a hero of course they
slide into this Catwoman scene where
they're slowly montaging across the
rooftops and I love the short hand that
they have like they just acknowledge
each other fat cat this is where we get
into deep Easter eggs so he references a
diamond the first time they met she was
trying to steal a diamond on a boat and
she's like oh we met in the street no we
met on the boat the diamonds that you
stole that I recovered I bought it years
ago and I've been keeping it this whole
time because even then that first moment
we met I knew and even before you turn
the page you kind of know where this is
headed the diamond diamond ring
engagement I'm so afraid will you marry
me so this is probably the bravest thing
that Batman has done in a long time and
he has fought dark side and parademons
so just blew me away probably one of the
best issues of Batman's that didn't
involve any actual fighting in a long
time
crazy rebirth this Batman story is the
best thing to come out of rebirth so any
Batman story where you go inside his
head is a lot of fun but this does it in
a really simple very elegant way the
really cool Easter egg if you're a
longtime Batman fan you probably know
exactly what this is
so he's referencing the first time that
they met it's the first appearance of
Selina Kyle in the comics it was Batman
number one in June 1940 so 67 years ago
this month that very first issue of
Batman was published now remember
Detective Comics is where he debuted but
they didn't start publishing the Batman
solo title till later in that issue
there was a story called the cat which
as you would expect Selina Kyle debuted
and she tried to steal a diamond
necklace disguised as an old one
on a boat Batman foiled her plan she
jumps off the back of the boat as he's
trying to holler in and just jokes to
himself you know what maybe I'll run
into her sometime again she had really
nice eyes rereading it now you just
think to yourself I see what you're
doing there Bill Finger setting up the
Catwoman to come back a billion times
but if you guys have read it let me know
what you think about it and where you
think it's headed so a lot of people are
saying that Batman and Catwoman are
getting married and that's not what's
happening he asked her to marry him that
doesn't mean that she'll accept and if
she does it doesn't necessarily mean
that it will stick because if you've
learned anything from weddings in the
comics weddings on Game of Thrones
it's usually bad when it's in a high
fantasy situation like this with so much
baggage that they're both bringing to
this relationship part of the reason
that it's never worked out between them
is one because of all the stuff that I
talked about with Bruce how he's been so
afraid this whole time and it's poisoned
all his relationships I don't know how
to not be Batman can Batman be married
to Catwoman Bruce Wayne can certainly be
married to Catwoman but Batman doesn't
really have relationships like that even
Talia Damian's mother was not a lasting
relationship very steamy love affair but
she ended up being a very bad person
even if you've only watched the animated
movies calleman still comes off is more
for protagonists so now I'm just so much
more excited to see her in the DC EU so
they can tease out that history between
her and Ben Affleck's Batman
the next big arc that they're teasing at
the end of this issue - the war of jokes
and riddles I don't know that that's
directly connected to this story because
they've been doing this thing in rebirth
where they'll take a block of comics
they'll tell a really self-contained
story then they'll move on to another
adventure but sometimes they're not
always continuous because you have
tie-ins with things like the flash in
the button but they will probably
reference this the next time you see him
in a comic book with the flash so just
doing an amazing job but if you want to
read more about this just read the flash
button then read this issue you can also
read the beginning of Batman rebirth
because that deals with the Gotham girl
character but you don't necessarily need
to understand who she is
to understand this story but a lot of
you have requested a longer flash Batman
Button video so I'll probably do that
later this week there's a really cool
Wonder Woman Superman Easter egg video
that I'm going to post Ned
there's like a really drawn-out
Superman's sequence that they did during
the movie
so that'll post later tonight in a
couple hours but congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner lone wolf please
private message me so I can get your
contact details there was a new round in
this video I'll just announce the winner
when I post that Wonder Woman videos
tonight while you wait for that click
here for a new flash and you can click
here for brand new Rick and Morty
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you